Chinese leader Xi Jinping had high hopes
that China's Global infrastructure
Investments would help expand beijing's
influence around the world
but with projects stalled and tens of
billions of dollars of loans going sour
Chinese officials are now reining in
China's massive Belton Road program so
let's take a look at where things went
wrong and five ways that Chinese
officials May retool Belton Road to try
to fix it
around the world you can literally see
how the Belton Road initiative or Bri
has run into problems
international airports built with
Chinese money are empty Deepwater ports
are underutilized and construction on
some Transportation projects has been
crawling some projects that are up and
running have saddled poorer countries
with billions of dollars worth of debt
which has prompted Belton Road backlash
in some places
to understand why there have been so
many problems I called my colleague
George Downs who's been taking a closer
look at a troubled Transportation
project what do you got for me George so
check this out Shelby this is obviously
a giraffe in the middle of Kenya and
running through the background is a
chinese-built railway China won the
contract because nobody else was allowed
to bid and China's ex-im Bank create a
loan that funded like 90 of it so
obvious question is the railway making
money uh it's really struggled too it
just hasn't carried as much cargo as it
needs to turn a profit so now Kenya owes
China a bunch of money a bunch of money
and it has a railway line that's kind of
a bit of a thorn in its side
to learn more about that Railway Project
Check out George's video here like many
countries Kenya is now struggling to pay
China back just as its economy faces
challenges like high inflation and
Rising interest rates some Western
leaders have called China's lending
practices debt trap diplomacy an
embarrassment to Beijing in a statement
this summer China is the ambassador to
Kenya said those allegations were pure
disinformation the Kenyan government
didn't respond to questions about our
story now not all of China's Investments
have been a bust in fact another project
in Kenya this super highway has been
economically viable and has improved
commuting Times by more than an hour
according to researchers at William and
Mary's Aid data research lab but as
those earlier examples show the complex
and nearly impossible to track Belton
Road initiative has run into some major
trouble obviously the fact that the
program now needs to be retooled shows
the limits to XI jinping's Ambitions of
reshaping the global order with Chinese
money and that's why Chinese officials
are pivoting to Belton Road 2.0
something wsj's Chief China
correspondent Ling Ling Wei says is a
priority at the highest levels of the
Chinese government the Chinese now want
to be more prudent and more selective in
terms of who they lend money to so here
are five ways that Belton Road could
change according to researchers who
study the program and people familiar
with policy making in Beijing first a
Slimmer portfolio Chinese banks have
already sharply reduced lending in
low-income countries and for now they've
stopped investing in some countries
altogether like Russia and Egypt that's
according to a report by the green
finance and Development Center at foodon
University in Shanghai secondly Chinese
banks are likely to favor smaller more
Nimble projects like hydropower plants
and solar farms and move away from
financing Mega projects like that
Railway in Kenya third they'll probably
invest more in digital infrastructure
like 5G networks and less in hard
infrastructure like roads and ports
already belt and Road engagement in the
tech sector has increased 300 percent
compared to last year according to that
food on University study fourth the ways
in which China finances projects is also
likely to shift for example instead of
lending directly to Central governments
which report public debt on government
balance sheets Chinese banks are likely
to invest more in public-private
Partnerships and Chinese Banks could
Syndicate more loans which essentially
allows them to share more risk with
other financial institutions these
practices could help China avoid bad
Investments and they could potentially
help root out corruption among the
governments that borrow money from China
but researchers say host governments
could still be on the hook for what they
call Hidden public debt and fifth
experts say that China may need to start
giving more money in the form of Aid and
less money in the form of loans if they
want Belton Road to be sustainable
according to an analysis by a data China
has provided nine dollars of debt for
every one dollar of Aid to low and
middle income countries it's the
opposite for the United States which
provides nine dollars of aid for every
one dollar of debt but there are some
major challenges when it comes to this
belt and Road overhaul in order for
China to move forward experts say it'll
have to renegotiate debt and potentially
even accept some losses when it comes to
the countries that already owe it money
economists estimate that nearly 60
percent of China's overseas loans are
now held by countries considered to be
an economic distress and some of those
countries like Sri Lanka and Zambia are
already experiencing debt crises balance
really are piling up they have to deal
with it if China is too lenient with
those countries it could Stoke tensions
at home where Chinese officials facing a
property crisis have resisted bailing
out the real estate sector but if China
refuses to take a haircut and accept
losses it could fuel anti-china
sentiment abroad and jeopardize
important political relationships plus
China now has competition on the global
stage we think that there's a much more
Equitable way to provide for the needs
of countries around the world the U.S
and G7 Nations announced a buildback
better World Partnership last year aimed
at countering China by addressing
infrastructure needs in the developing
World in a transparent and values-driven
way whatever happens lingling says that
Belton Road isn't going anywhere anytime
soon Chinese leaders including Xi
Jinping himself still see it as playing
an important role in promoting China on
the world stage
[Music]